when condom style went viral back in
2012 whuppin gotten them stars the world
got a glimpse of the flashy heavily
produced an entertaining nature of kpop
since then we've seen a lot such as
witnessing k-pop group BTS continuously
breaking records since 2017 black pink
being the first kpop girl group to
perform at Coachella and Super M being
the second k-pop group to reach number
one on the Billboard 200 Albums Chart
with all of that there's no doubt that
kpop has become a global phenomenon
while k-pop songs seem like standard
flashy pop songs they're actually a lot
more complex so what makes k-pop
different kpop songs features genre
twists mood changes and unexpected
musical turns most of them have at least
three songs built into one this started
back in 1992 when one of the earliest
k-pop groups sought to G and boys
experimented by combining heavy metal
jazz and ballet genres in one song this
helped reshape and modernize South
Korea's contemporary music scene one of
the most popular examples of genres
switching is girls generations 2013
release I got a boy
[Music]
my name is David amber I'm a music
producer and a songwriter and I've done
a lot of work in the kpop world could
you break down some of the elements that
you see are crucial in kpop from like a
writing perspective
I mean track wise there's just generally
a lot more going on hmm
traditionally there's more sections
there's more interesting chord colors
that are being used there's a lot of
people and the group loved it you'd be
like nine ten eleven people so there has
to be a lot of different parts those are
some of the things that are just
standard when we write songs genre k-pop
also changes things up by using chord
progressions influenced by jazz and
classical music which featured thicker
more harmonically dense chords in a
typical recent pop song the chord
progressions resolves neatly like in
Rihanna's stay one to six
four to six four to five but kpop
progressions often create harmonic
instability by using suspensions this
creates tension a suspension is when we
have an unstable chord such as this sus4
record and we resolve downwards apply
that to the chords to stay for example
[Music]
it might sound like that k-pops
progressions also use secondary
dominance also known as applied chords
as part of their chord structure just
like how each key has a 5 chord or a
dominant chord each of the diatonic
chords within the key have their own 5
chords so for example if we're going
from C major to a minor 1 to 6 we may
insert in between those two chords B 5
of 6 which is e major in this case and
it will sound like this
an example of secondary dominance and
jazz harmonies used in kpop is in red
Velvets one of these nights
suspensions and secondary dominant
chords help add complexity to kpop
melodies
this allows them to convey the emotions
and story of the song to listeners who
may not understand the lyrics kpop
nullities also do this by using modal
mixture which is when chords are
borrowed from the parallel key here we
have C major and C natural minor it's
parallel minor key as you can hear there
are some differences C major goes 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 whereas C natural minor goes 1 2
flat 3 4 5 flat 6 flat 7 when we go from
C major and instead of going to be major
for F major we're going to F minor which
is borrowed from the parallel minor key
it sounds like this
and that's what day six does in their
song cover what about lyrics
because it's in Korean most of the time
we'll write the song in English in
English okay yeah and once the label
decides that they want to cut the song
then a lot of times what happens is
they'll give the song to a bunch of
different Korean lyricist you're dealing
with a set of lyrics that takes you from
point A to point B but you're having to
accommodate multiple singers with
different characteristics I would
imagine that's very challenging we did
we demoed these songs okay and we try to
make them sound as close to what we
imagined the finish on would sound like
with the group singing on it so really
that comes down to top liners that I
work with or if we hire a demo singer so
they know this is the guy with the high
range this rappers got a deep husky tone
so like you know like cool like
beginning a character character yeah
another common musical technique in kpop
is key changes just like Disney
soundtracks and musicals the k-pop
industry loves its modulations mamamoo's
funky upbeat song you're the best is in
the key of F major for its verses and
then changes to the key of a-flat major
at the course jojoba shape another way
k-pop songs add color to their melodies
is by utilizing chromaticism
chromaticism refers to notes that are a
semitone above or below their adjacent
diatonic pitches here's a play in c
major scale and now with the chromatic
pitches in between the diatonic pitches
added
and you hear this type of chromaticism
in melodies maybe something like this
will sound like this
and you can hear it in the songs catchy
hook which makes the song sound bright
and playful the use of the Phrygian mode
in pop music has increased in popularity
and kpop is no exception in fact the
Phrygian mode is currently one of the
most commonly used modes in kpop the
main characteristic of the Phrygian mode
is the half step between the first and
second degrees which creates a
middle-eastern edgy badass typified the
major variant of the Phrygian mode known
as Phrygian dominant appears most often
in kpop songs
[Music]
kpop also rarely sticks to the typical
pop form of intro verse pre-chorus
chorus first pre-chorus chorus bridge
chorus and outro sometimes it's
difficult to know what section is what
in red velvet's Kasim Sala beem what is
used as a pre-chorus
in the beginning is later used as a post
chorus do you think over the last few
years kpop has really influenced Western
pop or the other way around I think that
you know Western pop generally the music
and the image is aimed a little bit
older uh-huh and it leaves this opening
or maybe like a One Direction used to be
okay pop I think does that better than
any other genre so I think in that way
it's really influenced worldwide culture
I can recognize certain sonic elements
of kpop but the specifics of it not
quite so if you have any suggestion for
me to you know they include this and
you'll you'll be you'll be closer
there's a lot more going on melodically
and also track wise what about the types
of sounds that I should use it can be or
anything but I just say that like it's
never there's never a moment where
there's not anything happening okay
always engaging yeah more is more in
k-pop okay more is more okay what's so
fun about kpop is that on the surface
level something may seem quite
mainstream and typical but if you look
closer at specific elements there's so
much more to be seen and heard kpop is
written so that listeners will be
consistently entertained by the changing
styles or unexpected pop form and now
that we've gone over what makes k-pop
music sound like kpop I'm going to
create my own original instrumental
track using some of k-pops musical
elements
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]